here's a Democrat representative on CNN
explaining that uh it's all the fault of
the voters of course what here's the
deal perception is reality and so when
you look at the data that was provided
in this poll it talks about how people
feel and when people decide whether
they're going to the poll or whether
they're not going to to the poll it's
all about how you feel in that moment
and so while the facts may not align
with their feelings their feelings are
dictating their reality their reality is
that they said that they feel better or
they felt better when Trump was in
office that is amazing I I I do love it
it's it according to this Democrat
representative on CNN what she is saying
is that black Americans are less
enthusiastic about Biden this time
around because they the black Americans
are emotional immature and ignorant
that's exactly what she just said